look not every movie is going to have
you on the edge you see after all they
can't all be Connor put the bone back in
the box still you think that if anyone's
going to stay awake through the whole
movie it's the actors who star in them
but that's not always how it plays out
whether out of boredom or sheer
exhaustion here are a few movie stars
who've copped to dozing off during their
own movies Michael Shannon there are a
few actors working today who are as
outspoken as Michael Shannon whether
he's going on a political read or trash
talking the entire movie industry
Shannon doesn't hesitate to say exactly
how he feels in the role of Zod Shannon
had one of the most crucial parts in
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice and
that's saying a lot since his character
was pretty much dead part of the time
but don't ask Shannon how the rest of
the film turned out because he slept
through the thing Shannon told Fandango
that the first time he tried to watch
the film he got punched by the Sandman
I watched it once and I fell asleep I
was on an international flight and I was
tired
Johnny death in 2015 depth and plenty of
praise for his performance as legendary
Boston crime boss Whitey Bulger in Black
Mass the drama went on to gross a
respectable 62 million at the box office
which occurred shortly after its
high-profile screening at the Venice
International Film Festival Depp was in
attendance to that or at least his
physical form was he later confessed on
Jimmy Kimmel Live that he didn't make it
all the way through the boovie movie
house close about 15 times as my wife
was telling ya it's not that he didn't
like the movie it's just that as he
explained he has quote a problem
watching films of any kind unless it's a
documentary one of the highest paid
actors alive paced watching movies ah
Brenton Thwaites Jeff Bridges tried to
bring Lois Lowry's young adult dystopian
classic The Giver to the big screen for
more than two decades
and when he began the process in the mid
nineties he envisioned his father Lloyd
Bridges in the title role by the time
the movie came out in 2014 though Jeff
Bridges himself was old enough to play
the giver the role of Jonah's the young
person who will save the world went to
Australian actor Brenton Thwaites
despite the career-making potential of
the pot weights actually dosed off the
first time he watched The Giver
he told Nova 106.9 they set up a
screening with me and Jeff I was so
tired that I kept falling asleep during
my own movie Shia LaBeouf
performance art stunts have kind of
become Shia LaBeouf's thing in recent
years not too long ago he decided to
live alone in a cabin in Finland for a
month just because he's Shia LaBeouf so
back in December 2015
Shia LaBeouf famously held a film
festival in his own honor at the
Angelika Film Center in New York titled
conveniently hashtag online movies the
film festival involves LaBeouf sitting
in a movie theater and watching every
movie he's ever starred in in reverse
chronological order that's about three
days worth of films so it's
understandable that LaBeouf fell asleep
at some point when he did finally doze
off
it was to Transformers Dark of the Moon
and he wasn't alone describing the event
he later said during transformers 2 they
could feel when I sunk in my seat that's
not a performative thing that's me going
through some kind of crisis and I'm not
the only one I remember right before I
fell asleep I looked next to me and the
guy next to me was falling asleep you
can see it on the screenshot we're both
asleep and the guy behind us is asleep
[Applause]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Applause]